[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos nous sommes
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est ici qu'est organisé la deuxième
édition du sky ce business d une
convention d'affaires qui réunit grands
groupes pme et tpe
mais tout de suite voici le sommaire
jean michel fourgous vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous en dira
plus sur ce concept qui a permis l'année
dernière de dynamiser l'économie de
notre territoire
immersion dans le village de
l'innovation plusieurs startups ont pu
profiter de cette journée pour mettre en
avant leurs services mais aussi trouver
de nouveaux partenaires
enfin découvrir les filières ou encore
les services pour les salariés de saint
quentin en yvelines
et bien c'est possible en quelques clics
grâce à la sky business map
elle a été présentée en avant première
lors de cet événement mais avant de vous
emmener au coeur de l'événement on va
commencer avec un chiffre six mille 500
c'est le nombre de rendez vous
d'affaires qui ont été programmés pour
cette deuxième édition c'est presque le
double par rapport à l'année dernière
chaque rendez-vous individuels dure 25
minutes et a été planifiée il ya
plusieurs semaines en fonction bien sûr
des besoins et des attentes exprimées
par les entreprises
le but développer les échanges avec des
partenaires locaux
[Musique]
et pour en parler en détail jean michel
fourgous vient de me rejoindre
bonjour vous êtes le vice-président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est vous inquiète à l'origine
de cet événement alors par rapport à
l'année dernière j'imagine le principe
n'a pas changé les entreprises enchaîne
les rendez-vous et multiplie les
contacts pensez bien ça principe
absolument dans une journée
nos entrepreneurs vont
avoir 3200 contacts commerciaux
prospects c'est à dire que vraiment ils
ne sont pas encore des clients mais on
leur donne toutes les conditions pour
donc
donc il augmente le nombre de clients
est en fait c'est bien le but
tout le monde parle d'emploi d'emploi
mais il y aura plus d'emplois si vous
augmentez l'activité économique de nos
entreprises donc c'est ce que l'on fait
en démultipliant leurs prospects donc
leurs clients vous augmenter leur
activité économique et donc bien sûr
l'emploi les rendez-vous dure 25 minutes
c'est possible en 25 minutes d'avoir
j'ai envie de dire un coup de foudre
professionnel pour un premier contact où
ils vous sentez si vous accrochez si
l'interlocuteur et crédible avec son
produit ce produit vous intéresse il le
présente bien ils se sont entraînés
avant parce que c'est une journée
importante pour eux c'est leur est
offert bien sûr que l'agglomération mais
cela dit c'est un moment important vous
séquence des cinq à dix prospère en une
journée vous vous préparez donc ils
savent ils ça ferait pas ils savent bien
vendre leurs produits leur valeur
ajoutée bien s'adapter leurs clients
trente minutes déjà pour un premier
contact c'est bien alors les entreprises
présentes ici sont exclusivement font
exclusivement partie du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la règle on est
on est en fait le coeur économique du
plateau de saclay si c'est là où vous
avez plus belles entreprises vont donc
donc c'est vrai que c'est cet espace de
saint quentin ses prestations
elles sont coûteuses action prélevé
aussi sur les entreprises sur sur le
contribuable sur est donc déçu elles
sont réservées aux l'événement bien sûr
c'est normal au aux entreprises de 50 à
d'où l'intérêt de venir s'installer à
saint quentin
alors le but donc c'est de booster un
vraiment l'activité des entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce que cela a été le cas après la
première édition du sky business day est
ce qu'au niveau des chiffres ça s'est
ressenti qui avait eu justement une
augmentation d'activité les entreprises
après le sky je dirais que je dirais
qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui
disent qu'est ce qu'il faut pour venir à
50 parce qu'ils sentent qu'il ya une
dynamique quand même original ici avant
et
et si ici on a fait deux fois plus d
espace d'entreprise en six mois que les
douze mois de l'année dernière c'est que
effectivement ça marche
nouveauté de cette édition 2010 est du
skate business day le village de
l'innovation 10 start up ont été
sélectionnés suite un appel à
candidature est présente sur leur stand
leurs innovations reportage
ici on retrouve des start up proposant
une application pour faire du sport ou
bien encore un procédé pour transformer
des déchets classiques
si certaines innovations sont d'ores et
déjà opérationnels d'autres sont encore
à l'état de prototype
exemple avec et i watch cette montre
connectés a été pas su attraper et a
pour vocation nous garantissons la
sécurité des personnes attendent
notamment de la maladie d'alzheimer au
cas de détection anormal chute ou
activités de type
la personne doit se réveiller à cette
heure mais elle est toujours pas aux
heures à ce moment là il ya une alerte
sms quand vous voyez les tirs watch a
reçu le prix des projets innovants lors
de la dernière soirée des entrepreneurs
de saint quentin en yvelines
elle devrait être testé début 2018 au
sein de l'ehpad plaisir grignon
en attendant l'entreprise cherche à
développer ses collaborations
aujourd'hui juste à côté on a notre
partenaire lui est né à canton a reçu un
collaborateur qui est très intéressé par
ce produit puisqu'il s'inscrit
directement dans leur périmètre faire
connaître son concept aux visiteurs du
sky business day c'est aussi l'objectif
de taken by un service en ligne qui
permettra très prochainement de se faire
livrer son repas sur son lieu de travail
tout en partageant les frais de
livraison avec ses collègues avoir un
stand au sein du village de l'innovation
a été très positif pour la start up on a
rencontré la banque populaire on a parlé
des financements c'est très important
pour une start up
il ya un effet de levier qui est
important pour nous pour qu'on puisse
développer notre solution et le groupe
hôtelier en europe hôtelier justement on
aimerait connaître leurs besoins en
matière de livraisons pendant cette
journée les dix startups sélectionnées
ont pu donner plus de visibilité à leurs
innovations et enrichir ainsi le réseau
[Musique]
rencontré approché de nouveaux clients
c'est l'objectif du
business des 600 entreprises sont
présentes aujourd'hui parmi elles le
crédit agricole d'ile-de-france bonjour
nicolas bon temps vous êtes responsable
du réseau des agences ile de france
ouest et à vos côtés breen d'iran brio
de sohar bonjour bonjour alors vous vous
êtes assistante commerciale pour la
société x démotion à coignières alors
c'est une société on va dire qui est
spécialisée dans les prises de vue
aériennes pour vous c'est la première
fois que vous participez au sky business
dès lors pourquoi vous avez décidé de
venir aujourd'hui
alors donc nous avons décidé
d'intervenir aujourd'hui à l'événement
fait de la réussite en fait que
cet événement a eu l'année précédente
est également là pour rencontrer toutes
les entreprises présentes sur le
territoire
cette nouvelle terre d'innovation que
représente
saint quentin alors c'est vous qui avez
rencontré des entreprises qui avaient
fait la demande alors ce sont plutôt les
entreprises qui vous ont sollicité alors
j'ai énormément sollicités
les entreprises mais c'est vrai que j'ai
eu également des demandes quels types
d'entreprises par exemple
alors moi je suis je me suis plus tourné
en fait vers le public on a l'habitude
d'avoir
notamment les entreprises basées sur les
événement sportif
voile alors nicolas bon temps vous c'est
votre deuxième participation au sky
business day alors j'imagine que si vous
êtes là c'est que la première édition a
été positif pour vous complètement tout
à fait positive
énormément de monde alors nous la
vocation de notre présence ici c'est
l'accompagnement de notre territoire
crédit agricole on a pas de sujet de
d'image de marque bien entendu mais
montrer qu'on est présent sur des
instants économiques importants du
territoire ça nous paraît essentiel
et puis ça nous permet de rencontrer
soit des futurs fournisseurs sur des
futurs clients
alors c'est vous justement qui avait
sollicité les entreprises comment ça
s'est passé on est plutôt sollicité
évidemment comme n'importe quel grand
groupe qui vient au sky business des
sont plutôt des gens qui essayent
d'accéder c'est pas facile d'accéder au
service achat d'un grand groupe au
service marketing d'un grand groupe
moi même c'est pas forcément évident
d'ailleurs en interne mais j'essaye de
jouer le rôle ici de facilitateur pour
des start up des entreprises murs des
entreprises moyennes qui ont du mal à
accéder à nos services centraux
acheteurs et je suis au comité de
direction du crédit agricole ile de
france par exemple
ça me donne quand même accès à des
décideurs et j'essaye de réorienter les
sociétés qui viennent me voir vers ces
acteurs là avec un petit mot sympathique
ce qui leur facilitera la vie ensuite
concrètement vous attendez quoi de cette
deuxième édition
c'est deuxième édition compte que l'on
voit beaucoup de monde on est
une dizaine du crédit agricole qui
tournant sur les différentes tables donc
de montrer que le crédit agricole c'est
un acteur de proximité un acteur de
territoire qui m a participé aux
événements économiques majeurs qui ce
qui s'y déroule
revenir en brie en soi même question
vous attendez quoi concrètement de cette
deuxième édition du skate business day
alors on attend de cet événement donc de
rencontrer de nouveaux collaborateurs de
nouveaux partenaires et ainsi d'étendre
notre rayonnement à l'échelle
territoriales locales on a moins de
sollicitations en terme
au terme locale voilà c'est pour
merci en tout cas à toi tous les deux
d'être intervenu sur ce plateau et que
j'ai envie dire bon business puisque
c'est aujourd'hui on du retour merci
merci aujourd'hui les entreprises
présentes ici ont pu rencontrer tous les
interlocuteurs qu'elle souhaitait mais
ils ont pu également découvrir un nouvel
outil mises à leur disposition
la sky businessman reportage
ces pictogrammes de couleur disséminés
sur l'ensemble du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines représentent les
services disponibles pour les
entreprises des hôtels des crèches ou
encore des lieux pour des séminaires une
carte interactive qui permet de partir à
la découverte de l'écosystème local
c'est toutes les ressources de saint
quentin en yvelines qui sont mises à
disposition des entreprises c'est pour
elles la possibilité de trouver un
fournisseur un partenaire un client dans
l'environnement local 3000
établissements sont référencés répartis
en plusieurs catégories filière
innovation compétences services aux
salariés
la carte est visible sur le site sky
entreprise.com on peut cliquer sur ce
qui nous intéresse et faire des
filtrages par selon nos critères
on cherche des filtrages par commune des
filtrages par un effectif et ensuite on
peut cliquer une fois qu'on a fait nos
recherches on peut cliquer directement
sur la fiche entreprise on retrouve
l'ensemble des informations essentielles
de l'entreprise
particularité de la sky business map il
est possible d'exporter le résultat de
sa recherche en format xl les
entreprises nous demandé deux choses 1
avoir une meilleure visibilité
avoir un outil un peu plus intuitif que
l'annulaire que nous avions jusqu'à
maintenant
et puis deuxièmement elles ont besoin de
pouvoir exporter le résultat ils ont
besoin de pouvoir utiliser les fruits de
leurs recherches pour venir en appui de
leurs actions commerciales
le site a été conçu pour qu'ils soient
simples d'utilisation et faciliter ainsi
les échanges entre les entreprises
saint-quentinoise cette émission touche
bientôt à sa fin mais avant de se
quitter on va jeter un rapide coup
d'oeil au rendez vous économiques qui
nous attendent
si vous êtes une entreprise issue de la
filière tourisme et que vous voulez
connaître les dispositions pour céder
votre commerce et bien sachez que lundi
23 octobre
la cci de versailles yvelines organise
une réunion intitulée la valorisation de
votre commerce est un préalable à sa
session ces deux 15h30 à 17h et c'est
gratuit
et puis mardi 24 octobre le cube
organise un atelier intitulé
communication numérique les passes pour
votre entreprise
il aura lieu de 9h à 12h la
participation est gratuite mais il faut
s'inscrire sur le site internet
www.skipass.com vous là c'est la fin de
ce fait fi des causses spécial sky
business des merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve le 31 octobre pour un
nouveau numéro
à très bientôt
[Musique]